hello everybody and welcome to part 9 of
let's play penumbra the Black Plague
when we left off we I just kicked the
ass of a worm finally probably the same
word that's been chasing me through the
whole game ah what Oh the valve yeah
it's not stuck now oh yeah there we go
so delete oh that easy why do you why
why did I even need to bother with that
did was that really necessary to add the
extra ten seconds to do that whatever
you're running around with a human body
part your backpack and I'm supposed to
be the bed hey don't judge me you
invaded my head oh look look look at a
body where'd that guy come from
oh did I kill him no I didn't kill him
oh you poor monkey Fred E is he all
right
he looks a little under the winter you
but maybe yes my ball I then me him sure
if I were me I'd envy him as well uh how
do you commit suicide when you got no
heart to stop no hands to will the
chainsaw oh shut up
get my flashlight back all right where
am I going
I got my hand I can I think I can go
back to the infirmary with seven seven
residential cord all right whatever
touch it on my way um let's see Oh that
doors blocked yeah right whatever all
that's where it came out okay oh oh
maybe this was where I came in
I should probably yeah alright nevermind
sorry sorry guys and me to waste your
time uh-huh uh-huh yeah okay this is
residential Oh gasps the spiral biology
take their work home with that huh no
kidding
all right boom door jump lady 360 door
jump all right human hand apparently aah
so what did you open the door really
uh-oh oh no oh no I'm dumb I'm dumb I'm
dumb the library that's why I was
getting a hand in the first place that's
stupid [ __ ] decided to not give me his
hand and instead cut off a part of him I
don't even know what he cut off but it
looked gross and then try to kill me
what I sure what a big jerk wad that's
an oven mitt not a hand
oh I scanner oh I need an eyeball what
do I do there's a guy there there's a
dead guy but how do I get his eye out uh
something in the army I do I have a note
nope
pom iris door to cryo chambers locked up
boy all right I didn't get a chance to
check in there flare it's in here
anything nope nothing
nothing ever use uh where's that dead
guy machine room oh that sounds
interesting
oh no that's not interesting at all
they're mine see oh there he is
hello hello friend give me your eyeballs
give give eyeball eyeball gimme oh shut
up uh poke it out with a hand oh he has
him I know I know he has him oh I know
he hasn't ah all right fine fine fine
great place I haven't been uh man
dum-dum-dum emergency airlock six five
changing oh yeah oh yeah the the room
the monster came out of yeah some
monster didn't do much
Oh what's this but it looks so bad Boop
all right in here
I'll spoon or something give me
batteries ah damn it
darn oh come on what did I miss what did
I miss
what did I miss all right just checking
checking around more times that spire
still here
oh the flashlights so useless
they're so useless ah so useless
anything anything at all anything at all
no
nope uh you're uh you're useless all of
you are so useless
alright screw this screw this
come on all you I'm gonna a mother uh uh
get me up there you uh ah I'm gonna kill
someone if you don't yeah thank you
thank you very much sir oh all right
scoffs tough stuff nothing I can use
went in there
oh maybe oh oh yeah ah let me go back to
the crazy guy maybe maybe maybe maybe I
can get something from him
thank it I remember when he was running
at me one part of his face was not
bloody and that just happened to contain
an eyeball get me or I I will beat it
out of you until you are dead or at
least eyeless um why don't you give it
oh I will gimme I am so ready Fu Fu man
oh uh uh losing intelligent thought guys
right who's intelligent connecting the
dots all right fine fine fine rusty
metal lockers nothing in here door
controller
nothing in here all right this room and
storage have been checked
as long as well as the armory it's only
so many places I can go oh let me go
back to the infirmary there must have
been some reason for that hand scanner
that I missed
must have been lust a man oh man
what did I miss otherwise it was staring
me right in the face wasn't it oh man
you guys think I'm so stupid
oh I think I'm so stupid all right what
was the reason for this okay
phenomenal now why this why Croucher
thank you so much approach you with a
hand a foot I am at darn you chemical
test no report don't
did it open the rest of the drawers yep
okay um oh wow
I am failing hardcore hardcore failure
hardcore failure oh do I have like a
screwdriver or something I know the dead
body it's right there he's got eyes I
want him I want his eyes I want them ah
so mad so mad
Oh mad all right oh I've been everywhere
I've been everywhere everywhere
no notes nothing whole lotta nothing
oh the only place I haven't
double-checked is the machine room so
I'd might as well
Oh God so Oh hello dead guy you're so
useless to me
oh I have fingernails can we get him out
another finger nails the eyes I just
realized how crazy it is I'm running
around screaming I want eyeballs and not
so crazy all right
you nothing you nothing a lot of nothing
there was a sturdy metal rod maybe I
could find a way to get that engines out
of order you're out of order
Oh cards out of order sturdy metal rod
again I can try that I couldn't get it
through the door anyway there was
nothing in here nothing at all
nothing in there oh that's it oh that's
it
that's it all right well I hope you
enjoyed the Let's Plays um so oh ah damn
it
false hope level 89 billion ah right oh
so mad oh I'm so mad I'm so mad so so
mad angry okay I'm gonna have a sincere
talk with you I need your eyeballs you
are dead
two plus two equals give me your eyes
I'm gonna write in your eyeball right
I'll get your whole head why can't I
just take your head alcohol oh oh all
right guys I'm sorry I'm sorry I failed
hardcore I'm gonna figure this out so I
don't waste you guys as time is so
annoying
all right I will see you in part ten
nine eight ten ten bye-bye